who's this woman she's my secretary sir
she's a very good secretary welcome to
your weekly ticket well you'll never
believe what's leading at the box office
this weekend because it is Star Wars The
Empire Strikes Back yeah that's right it
earned an estimated 175,000 at 483
locations according to Deadline
screenings of The Empire Strikes Back
this summer have coincided with the 40th
anniversary of the film which originally
arrived in theaters on May 21st 1980 and
of course with the ongoing koban 19
pandemic drive-in screenings of classic
titles have been the primary option for
moviegoers looking to get out and watch
something but the pandemic hasn't
shuttered all productions
zendaya and John David Washington just
announced a completed filming for their
upcoming title malcolm and marie the
movie which is by euphoria creator Sam
Levenson was shot between June 17th and
July 2nd in Carmel California
zendaya initiated the project calling
Levinson and asking him if he could
write and direct a movie during
quarantine within six days he created
Malcolm and Marie
zendaya posted a black-and-white photo
of her and John David Washington from
set to share the news and Brad Pitt is
set to star in action thriller bullet
train for Sony Pictures the film is
based on the Japanese novel Maria Beetle
and will be directed by Deadpool
director David Leitch the movie tells
the story of five assassins who find
themselves on the same train from Tokyo
which undoubtedly leads to lots of
action Pitt will play an American hit
man named ladybug gray he took my
nickname now what am I supposed to go by
well it's the middle of the summer and
we're celebrating by highlighting some
of our favorite summer blockbusters
check out our summer blockbuster list
which highlights the top summer films
since 1975 on Fandango now and here to
help us with a selection is ET zone ash
crossing ash what he got for us okay
when I think of summer blockbusters
especially this year I have to recommend
Wonder Woman the 2017 movie directed by
patty Jenkins starring gal gadot and
Chris Pine the sequel was set to come
out June 5th
so she should have already seen the
sequel should have already been in our
eye holes we should have already seen
80s Dianna but I digress
it's also comic-con season and when I
think of Hall H I think of gal gadot
she's become like an outstanding
presence on that stage and I'm really
gonna miss her this year so I'm just
gonna go back and watch Wonder Woman by
the way if you somehow haven't seen it
no judgment but I do think it's a really
good entry point to the DC because
there's not a lot of homework and we
don't like homework in the summer so go
ahead and watch that one she's so cute
she's such a fish out of water in it she
goes to London to try to stop world war
one she's very ambitious and her
chemistry with Chris Pine is just
unmatched and a very big shout out to
Lucy Davis as Edda by the way because
she is just comedy in this movie so I'm
going with Wonder Woman kill what is
your bechamel the sad Verte iseman for
the next Wonder Woman are incredible oh
don't like images they have for it I
have to I have to quickly just show you
oh no I wonder if my movies my
background alright
the movie I chose and I think you should
watch again or if you haven't seen it
already is spider-man the 2002 Sam Raimi
spider-man which arguably started this
whole superhero movie trend like really
Kipp kicked it into overdrive
it is crazy it's very intentionally
comic book II it's it's really it's
really quirky and fun and if you haven't
seen it you're gonna be surprised at how
different it is from the Marvel movies
we have nowadays and also so many memes
came from there you'll be caught up on
so many memes and also you'll finally
get to decide which spider-man you
actually like the best hmm
you have an opinion on that ash my
favorite spider-man is spider-verse I
have to say straight over okay you know
what
yeah yeah I do feel like recently a lot
of people are going back to the Sam
Raimi films so I definitely support this
pick yeah absolutely
I love it it just if it's frozen in time
as its own little comic book movie and
director Sam Raimi is directing the
upcoming Doctor Strange movie Doctor
Strange into the multiverse of madness
so you'll get a sneak peek into his
style all right well thank you so much
ash make sure to check out Entertainment
Tonight and also ash on her own personal
accounts but in case you needed some
other recommendations and some things to
look forward to here are some extra pics
with sequels in the works Steven
Spielberg's massive 1993 blockbuster
follows two dinosaur experts Alan Grant
and Ellie Sattler and a mathematician
named Ian Malcolm who were among a
select group chosen to tour an island
theme park populated by dinosaurs
created from prehistoric DNA while the
park's mastermind billionaire John
Hammond assures everyone that the
facility is safe they soon find out
otherwise as predators break free and go
on the hunt critics and audiences seem
to agree on this one giving in a 91
percent on the tomato meter and an
audience score to match since the
original Jurassic Park film there have
been four other installments the lost
world Jurassic Park Jurassic Park 3
Jurassic world and Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom the next installment Jurassic
world Dominion is currently scheduled to
hit theaters on June 11 2021 laura dern
jeff goldblum and sam neill are set to
appear throughout the film and not just
in cameos a trio of university
parapsychologists lose their research
grant and decide to open their own
business
ghostbusters and are summoned to
investigate the strange happening in a
Central Park West apartment what they
discover is that all Manhattan is being
besieged by otherworldly demons the new
Ghostbusters installment Ghostbusters
afterlife is currently set to be
released in theaters on March 5th 2021
Vin wolfhard Carrie [ __ ] and McKenna
Grace will appear in lead roles for this
film and let us know in the comments
what is your favorite summer movie of
all time
I'm kale and I'll see you next time
[Music]